hi guys it's self ret again and I
decided to use my old intro again
because this is a very special occasion
and you may ask why's there's a special
occasion well as you might notice I'm
not moving around as much on the
time-lapse and that's something that I
thought of and I have no idea how it
took me like 13 months or something like
that to think of this as well as the
other already out there let's players
who are also doing this but I figured
that I might as well try and build in
such a way that the time lapses actually
don't move around all the time and even
though this was actually quite annoying
and of course I did have to move around
quite a lot because obviously you're
gonna have to look at buildings from
many sides and stuff but I tried to not
look around when placing objects on one
side for example as I'm doing right now
and even though it seems like I'm kind
of moving around quite a lot on the
time-lapse that's because it's sped up a
times but yeah but that's the idea now
this was kind of not that great of an
idea and I always kind of well didn't
want to do this because of course if I
actually build things I don't do it with
the idea of making a nice height and
time lapse of course that's just a nice
product that I get because I'm recording
but then again it's not the most
important thing the most important thing
is of course to get the building done
right and at this point I would have to
concentrate less on the building and
also on the way that I'm building it so
I don't know if that's a good idea but
then again it did prove well pretty
successful at least making a good video
and the thing that I got in the end
wasn't all that bad and I'm actually
pretty happy about it but you'll see
that in a moment of course and really my
explanation to this entire building also
I'm gonna add another building to this
and you're gonna see that one as well
but my only explanation that I have to
this is to kind of go into the general
style that I already had going for this
bike it's very similar to the buildings
done I have throughout the park it has
that same and all that spire is
absolutely horrendous it's a good idea
that I removed that Bing but what I
wanted to do with this building anyway
was to get something over there because
I needed something and then at some
point I was like oh dammit
I need a restaurant and somebody
well didn't request it houses that a
request somebody said that I should
build a restaurant and I was like yeah
that's actually a good idea because I
have this huge park and only one tiny
restaurant so I decided to build another
one next to this building and this
building by the way is completely
useless as in I don't know what kind of
function it should have there are too
many buildings in this bike which don't
have any function other than oh it looks
cool
that's just my idea about this bike if
you want to build realistic stuff do not
look at this bike or at least you can
look at it but then this regard its in
terms of how you should build because
this is not very realistic I just wanted
to go over the top and do whatever I
want and this is starting to become the
result of that though that it's not
meant in a very negative sense just kind
of a neutral I suppose but yeah this
building is very similar in a sense that
of course I'm using shyguys alpine
village again especially for the roofs
because I actually did here's someone
complaining about and that was in the
sky by the way that I used these roofs
to open and I was I looked at I am like
yeah I've been doing that for years
actually and the reason for that is
they're user-friendly but they also look
good they have the nice sexy wooden
beams and I don't know what I just like
them I like to use them and I like the
look of them and I rather overuse these
things then use other roofs because I do
have plenty of other roofs that I also
know how to work with and also have but
then again I like them less and I'd
rather just have something that I like
the look of and disregard the fact that
I've already used it very often in
various projects and I usually say that
you have to get away from your comfort
zone but in this case my comfort zone
can fit into things that are not my
comfort zone and that would be shy gains
alpine village roofs plus steampunk and
industrial and spooky and all that but
aside from that this building is not
that as I said this buildings not that
different but I decided to add some
other elements in this building that I
haven't added or haven't added very
often in other buildings and one of
those things is I
I decided to actually use my walls from
my sci-fi set which I absolutely hate
and that's the reason why I've never
actually really released any of my
custom scenery sets but you can download
them in my style themed for this so I
suppose I don't feel too guilty about
that because I do always nag about
others who don't release no customs in
resets but I think that's beside the
point
but anyway I felt that it might be
useful and it it proved pretty useful
especially those hikes if I did feel
like this set would have a use those
arcs are their sole reason and the
texture of the roof of course but that
was Google Images not me I just had to
look for brick walls and searching
Google Images long enough before I got
anything and I don't know if that's a
copyright issue but it's I think it was
actually a copyright free one so I don't
give a [ __ ] and this at this point I
started working on the restaurant and by
the way that black little thing over
there is gonna be a future flat ride I
still just have to install some plant
rights because that's me once again I
did install a couple flat rides but then
I didn't install them right and I also
tried getting imaginary John's pirate
ship but then everything crashed and I
was like no this is not happening and
then I just removed it again so make it
square one so I'm gonna have to find
some sea you Florence actually and I'm
not that good at that because I never
really spent too much time with that
because even though I've been playing
roller coaster in three four years I've
only started getting into parks for like
two years maybe three and I still don't
even have too many CFR's because every
time I would build a park I would get
the specific sea of ours that I wanted
and this saves time but I wouldn't
recommend doing it because for one if
you want other CFR's you're gonna have
to close your game again and find
another CFI and it's gonna take you ages
and if you do have many sea you're
forcing your game it might lag the game
up but then again you might get some
ideas from it or just place one anyway
because you have it already so I'd say
that's a better idea than doing what I'm
doing and not have any CFR's but yeah
that's that also I didn't say yet this
yet but I've actually been inspired by
western themes
this building I kind of like the pillows
I don't know there's just that kind of
neoclassical influence those pillars
with the cornices that kind of has that
around our key feeling on it it just
makes it like it's an Oracle your
classical pillars or something I don't
know I like it it's very much like it's
an actual classical building but except
it's made out of wood and other random
things and at this point I was kind of
trying to get a right little edge for
the wall over there
I thought at some point that I could
make a custom series set which would
have random stones that you could place
on the edges of walls because I can see
that many people keep using the same
ones as in shy guys out by village 3 has
those things and Pat's efteling set has
those things how many people use the
same ones but there's not too much of a
variety there is there is of course
Ralphie's beaver homes one but that kind
of has a weird texture that's very light
and didn't really work on the themes
like this but I guess that's an idea
I'll play around with later on and at
this point actually I didn't really like
the shape of the building and I still
think it makes no absolutely no sense
it's a weird building really and it
doesn't have any interiors because I had
no idea how to tackle that I'm not too
sure if it actually looks like a
restaurant except for of course the
outside with all the tables and oh so
cute
I don't know why I like tables oh that
came out wrong I do anyway yeah yeah now
you can conclude that I like tables I
don't know what I just liked the look of
them that's that's it pretty much
and the same goes for those windows
anyway and at that point I looked at
station ships gardening think this is -
and was like what's this and there's
that weird thing and I have no idea what
it what that actually is it's supposed
to be like yeah if I was something I've
no idea what to actually do with those
things I sometimes I need to look that
up because I'm scenery sets but I'm sure
I'm not the only one when it comes to
this but sometimes you just have because
some scenery sets any of these objects
and of course isn't for me because
they're not even a native English
speakers sometimes I don't even know the
words but why do I tell me I need to
stall down Ioannina but then it you have
these pieces and a custom series that
you just have no idea what to do with it
and you wish you could actually look
into the brain because
create and be like what did you mean for
me to do with this thing
and then I go ahead and do something
with it that you're totally not supposed
to do and that's kind of how I feel
about those wooden things underneath
thee is it even a balcony it's not a
beer either I guess it's a balcony Peter
or whatever you call those things and I
don't know why if that's actually what
I'm supposed to do but it looks cool so
yeah why not go for it I I would say
that sometimes you just have to screw
realism in the most simple ways and just
go for whatever looks cool or whatever
you like of course because that also
makes sense I decided to add at those
lights because apparently those lights
don't make any sense when it comes to
the theme of this park but that's just
what I love about the theme of this park
because as soon as people say hey
doesn't make sense that's not correct
then isn't that's like an anachronism or
something like that I could say no this
theme it makes no sense I am right you
are wrong my opinion is correct and
anyway that sounds really terrible but
that's it for this episode so thank you
for watching and bye on nice buildings
though I'm glad that I got these things
done in this episode